this man is multi-talented to say the
least
Odyssey and greatest hit still greatest
hit still is going to be released on
October 2nd enjoyed his work for all
those years as Bo Duke on Dukes of
Hazzard Smallville with dr. Quinn
Medicine Woman and now Dancing with the
Stars season 27 good to see you John
amazingamazing thank you good I just I
can't believe it I'm I'm dumbstruck
right now I did not know what we just
discussed in the television only segment
the generally yes guarantee owned by
Bubba Watson yeah
Masters winner multiple drunk Rosie and
the year he wanted he had just bought
that car and he had it in the parking
lot so he pulled the clubs out of it
unless somebody brought him but I think
by have no Bubba so he's the kind of guy
that would have pulled the clubs out of
the trunk of the General Lee and gone
and won the Masters and you know thrown
his throne his climb in the window
through the green jacket in the back
seat and took off yelling yeehaw is that
how you met is that how you met Bubba
I meant Bubba because he had purchased
the car oh there it is he bought the car
and that is the number the oh one not
the old one yeah that but the first car
we had right and he wanted me to sign it
for him out in Scottsdale okay and I
said I'll sign it but I have to play
around a golf with you so he brought me
out and I signed the car we played a
round of golf which was just
unbelievable and yeah and he's had the
car ever since I think it's great so
your player right you play golf I am and
I you know I want to play golf well so
badly is a great way to put it yeah I
have two regrets in life one that I
didn't start golf sooner and one that I
started golf at all that's it just kicks
my butt it does it really just tells I
was talking to DeMarcus Ware about
because DeMarcus is on Dancing with the
Stars yes and we think that the hardest
that the reason why golf is so hard and
why maybe a happy gilmore got it right
is that happy gilmore turned it into a
reaction you know cuz when you play
ping-pong you're you're reacting when
you're out window we talked to DeMarcus
when you're out there playing football
you are reacting to a lot of things
enter your training and your physicality
is coming into it and your sense of
survival and to want to kill somebody is
all in there
but with golf is just sitting there and
it's saying dude I'm sitting here hit me
anyway you want however hard you want
and I'm just sitting here we and it
takes two sports the the physicality out
of it yes it does it kind of mocks you
in a way it messes with your it does you
got that's where the golf ball says if a
golf ball could speak it would say what
you got my we won said didn't we we had
once we had Pete Rose on a great love
Pete Rose he also talked about how he
doesn't think golf is that difficult I'm
like what are you talking about he cuz
the ball is not moving he goes I had a
hit a boy I had I hit a moving you know
he goes I had no idea where it was
coming from how it was coming at me fast
yeah but it's it's fast twitch muscles
and all sorts of stuff that come into
play survival comes into play somebody's
throwing a ball 100 miles an hour ahead
and you're gonna want to hit it that's
right yeah but golf is tough because
it's just sitting there so what's tough
for golf or dancing dancing is like is
like trying to learn a thousand
different golf strokes mm-hmm yeah so I
think I think dancing would the golfing
stars would be a great idea
now I really do because it's it's hard
you've got to think about where your
left or your say I'm or that's why I'm
not very good at it where your right
pinky is and your left little toe is so
that Len doesn't call and where your
elbows are sure depending that was a
Foxtrot and and depending upon the dance
it's it's all about like a golf swing if
your head is in the wrong place then
your feet are in the wrong place and the
balls you're gonna slice the ball I
don't know if you saw phil Mickelson's
recent commercial for his new
button-down golf shirt his dress shirt
button-down long-sleeve golf shirt but
he might have already started piloting
dancing with the golf stars cool he has
he did some dance moves and a leg kick
did he really it was something you know
it's not the old joke about the golf
shirt where you you tie you tie a string
around your man parts and to your button
to keep your damn head
No he goes Wow what do you think the
radio is I not see that okay radio
audience Phil Mickelson Wow okay I've
never seen no no no waving at the singer
those moves oh come on really what
outfit how fast would he be voted off
Dancing with the golf stone oh I think
he did well show me the flaws so John
Schneider here now you realize that you
are not the only John Schneider on I'll
do it correct I do realize that yes and
are we are we on radio we are on radio
good then you know you're a Michigan guy
so I'm gonna have to tell you I think
the two most underrated running backs to
ever play at Michigan in my opinion oh
you come correct with our Jamie Morris
and Tim whose name I can hardly
pronounce so I'm gonna be occupied to
Jaap be Aqaba touka well done right and
yeah so I think what do you think about
that do you agree no these are not notes
this is just I'm just since we're on
radio this was just coming to my mom
okay what else is on your mind John what
else is on my mind is I'm wondering did
Bo my namesake Schembechler yeah did he
actually attend Michigan he did not he
went to the Maya he went to Miami did
not he went to Miami of Ohio which is
also referred to as the cradle of
coaches bingo we have a winner we have a
winner can you name any other famous
Miami Ohio coaches besides Bo
can i phone a friend on this we could
phone a friend phone me I want to phone
a friend right now John Schneider
general manager of the Seattle Seahawks
are you on the phone line right now
what's happening guys thank you John how
are you buddy everything's good I'm
trying to do your proud here I know you
got to rip the names off well what do
you haze of course I mean come on I
happen to be watching television today
woody clocked that kid is that right
yeah yeah I was watching that with you
being on the show John don't don't worry
how about what about Gary Moeller molar
come on so do you guys John I believe I
know I need to do this properly football
John Schneider how do you know how do
you know actor John Schneider Seahawks
general manager John Schneider here on
the phone right now
yes John a mutual friend an agent named
Brett test or hooked us up yep yeah and
so I was you know I was that kid Friday
night 7 o'clock and you know sitting in
the family room couldn't wait for you
know do that come on that's my guy
I think it's so great John and I I have
this thing called talk Walker alerts ok
and I kept that's how I learned so much
about you John because I would my name
would kept popping up and I'm thinking
what have I done to get all this press
was it me no it was you it was you so
hopefully you've got some of my press at
least it's you know it's woken you up in
the middle of the night you thought oh
what wonderful thing have I done now
did you know you're on Dancing with the
Stars talking about me right that's
right exactly
so we alert each other now John Snyder
of the Seahawks has anybody anybody ever
thought that you were actually the John
Schneider to my right has that ever
happened to you
actually when I started the league
checking into hotels and stuff like that
you know and you know the courtyards and
that sort of stuff at schools going to
school cause people would be like you're
not related to the real Wow
Wow that's about that's about it but
more people will be like hey he's okay
bike you know you know if I call you Bo
I was a huge dude oh my gosh I love that
I love that I did I had some people
think I was you like think I took up
like you are a Super Bowl architect yeah
they thought yeah it was it's
interesting what people think it's just
it's interesting because you know they
do everything is they read it and they
think it's true now so there's another
John Schneider - that's a friend what
and I don't know if you know this other
John Schneider or not John Schneider
his name is oddly enough John Schneider
and he is Rob Schneider's brother really
and my brother's name is Bob and his
friends call him Rob so we've got the
the John Schneider trio I think I think
do you sing John know you can hold the
sheet music up and we'll sing it's so
great to talk to you next time I get up
there we're gonna do a concert tour so
when I get up there hopefully we'll be
able to actually connect like Facebook
friends and but do you guys text and do
I text this morning and I said give me
some information and make me sound smart
[Laughter]
just like like you and read up sure he's
been on a John I just avoided that one
I've been called Snyder for I'm in the
south so I've been called Snyder a lot
so you know I try to avoid the multi
syllabic names yeah it's not and why
that's exactly it Snyder thank you very
much
John Snyder up in the Pacific Northwest
thanks for calling in how to cook this
up great you're our go-to guy John there
he goes you're gonna be surprised yeah I
said make me look smart I want to do
stark bench cut with you if you don't
okay a little of little Tiger Woods huh
oh sure we can hit that too John
Schneider here on the Rich Eisen show
it's gonna be quiet
Orkut okay so we give you three choices
you must start one you must bench one
you must cut one okay these are these
can be difficult you mean one can't play
you don't cut one cog nomads like that
means a whole different thing where I
came from cut out okay only one place
one's benched and one is cut here we go
John Schneider start bench cut the best
Duke out there currently John Elway
whose nickname is the Duke the football
whose nickname is the Duke there's it's
called the Duke because of Wellington
Mehra's nickname was Duke back in the
day the owner of the joints or Duke
basketball which one's the best Duke out
there okay you start la I start Elway
you benched the football or Duke
basketball I benched it I'd bench the
basketball okay and then you cut the
football oh yeah footballs out yep
you're a golfer I'm a golfer well but
I'm we give we give homage to football
with Elway and we okay you know we share
it I understand I can't have two
football next one up for John Schneider
start bench cut most iconic 80s
automobile the General Lee KITT from
Knight Rider or the DeLorean from Back
to the Future well you start the General
Lee okay
you cut kit and you bench because it's a
wannabe car you could actually get that
car the General Lee was already an old
car when we started okay DeLorean had
something I knew John DeLorean so you
had to add some things to make the Back
to the Future car the KITT car was
really kind of appropriately named KITT
car this is not a John Schneider
Hasselhoff feud that I just wouldn't
stand a chance that would last one for
you start start bench cut okay best 80s
villain who wore a cowboy hat Oh jr.
Ewing from Dallas Boss Hogg from Dukes
of Hazzard or Buford T justice from
Smokey you use some I tell you what I
apologize to Larry uh-huh so I would
start view 40 Justice I would bench Boss
Hogg
I'd have to cut jru yep I mentioned jr.
Ewing a lot because I do a show called
the haves and have-nots Tyler Perry's
show the haves and have-nots and I play
a guy that makes jr. Ewing look like a
choirboy that's yeah
yeah I used to say like a Catholic
priest but I don't say that anymore
because yes you shouldn't say that but I
so I play a I play a really nasty
terrible guy on this show and I loved
every minute of it loved Larry Hagman
but one of the nicest most wonderful
people I've ever worked well he was a
doll oh you must find it a bunch of like
up front stream of Genie fan so I loved
Larry Hagman and sorrell booke from
Buffalo New York was a consummate actor
spoke seven different languages he
played boss hogg so he spent seven
different eyes yes he was an amazing
which language did he use with boss huh
he made that up actually he did he would
tell you why boss hogg pronounce words
cuz he wouldn't say dollars he would say
samolians and he would say he says that
word because he grew up here his parents
were from such-and-such and he went to
school block so he was he was I would
say a consummate wordsmith and uh what
if you study that a linguistics major
yes so he was he was delightful and my
gosh I grew up I love the honeymooners
and I love the Jackie Gleason show and
when she I was actually climbed the
fence and biessed my way onto the set of
smoking the Bandit come on spent a day
with Jackie Gleason what yeah yep I
spent I was 16 years old I spent the day
with Jackie Gleason there was a kid
beside him with a red was it Radio Flyer
sure with a keg in it and Jackie would
just he would be talking about stuff cuz
I'm from Mount Kisco and I think Jackie
was from like Scarsdale we're both from
Westchester County so we had that in
common and he just would hold the hold
the mug out and the kid would feel fill
the mug up and he just yeah it was a set
of smokey in the Bandit yes and I'm in
the very end of it if the very end
credits when they freeze frame Sally
says good no hard feelings jr. and then
the car runs off and the the Cadillac
comes up they freeze-frame a tire hits
this big goofy-looking kid with
cowboy hat in the shins and that's me at
the end so I'm actually in it until they
threw the whole credit roll but I got a
free lunch thank you
I love that all right before we go you
wanna you want to give me your golfing
Mount Rushmore Tiger said it was sneaky
I've my theory is that this whole time
Tiger has sucked that what he's been
doing is he's been putting balls in the
water intentionally he's been aiming for
the lily pad so actually what he's been
doing is he's been playing the best golf
he's ever played but dope yeah well well
you can't you cannot stage a comeback
unless you've gone away mm-hmm so he
staged a comeback he was very he was a
very unusual Tiger Woods he was so
humble the other day and he should have
waited a month or so if somebody else
should have said that that's he should
not have said that that is the most
tinfoil sports take I've heard in quite
some time I'm not sure what that means
that means they can for their very
conspiracy theorists right there like a
tin foil come on it would be like like
Elway not being able to throw I mean
let's you cut his arm off then maybe you
can't throw a football so what's your
who's your Mount Rushmore John Schneider
you're golfing round Mount Rushmore if
you had to put for golfers up oh well
I'd put him in there I just wouldn't I
wouldn't have put okay me in there if I
were him because people were just
talking about sure this is an entirely
different Tiger Woods
he's so appreciative he's so friendly
he's so thankful he's so humble he's a
changed man and he just he just he just
threw that out with both hands he did he
did and he didn't even grin after it oh
yeah yeah because he's absolutely beyond
question he deserves to be there
absolutely with who but you do not you
do not when you win the humility award
you do not wear it that's a great one
it's still released on October 2nd yes
I'm John Schneider studios.com right or
John Schneider studios on Facebook yeah
Alicia and I we make movies we've made
seven films since we met we've released
will release 662 songs this year for a
Guinness Book of World Records and
they're all great they're all singles
each and every one of them
John Schneider studios.com that I say it
yet John Schneider studios.com well done
John underscore Schneider and dancing
and then Dancing with the Stars season
premiered with the two-hour special
Monday and Tuesday every single Monday
and Tuesday at 8:00 Eastern Time yes you
go John I'm gonna by golly I'm gonna try
my hardest we got to take out D where
you got to take out the markets Auto
Mike at the very least I don't know what
that man is a force
I'm not saying take him down no no no
boy he is what what a sweetheart so he
is he's what a sweetheart he's a
hall-of-famer and every year yes and he
in every sense and his mom was there on
Monday night which was so great so so
great well don't let that fool you
though take him no no no I don't even he
might have cast her it might not even
really been his mom above that spirit
see taken his way out the door good to
see you what if people are following you
maybe they are thank you that's John
underscore Snyder the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience